hey guys welcome back to the gains but
stage at the final day of e3 I'm cam
Robinson I'm in my comfortable orange
chair and it's great to be here I'm
gonna be sad to leave are you gonna be
sad to leave Ollie this is ollie by the
way everybody hey I'm doing I'm doing
well thanks are you sad to leave III uh
it's been hectic but I always have a lot
of fun when I mirrors great to see all
the new games coming out and some new
ip's as well and it's pretty exciting
times in the games industry give new
games you've grown a new game along as
well what why you at e3 what are you
shouting about well we're here to tell
everyone about hitman sniper it's the
second game from Square Enix Montreal we
released hitman go probably a couple of
months ago now actually yeah and hit me
and sniper is a second game that we're
we're doing in the with the Hitman
franchise now the Beco the gist of the
game is essentially it's a fixed
position sniping game yeah it's a leader
board based highly competitive and it's
all about how your kind of creatively
killing your your marks throughout the
scene so you've got one guy that you've
been hired to kill and the game is based
around taking your time to draw out the
tension and kill him at exactly the
right moment whilst you're building up
points around the scene fantastic well
let's have a look at that we got teaser
trailer I think right yes we gotta try
that and then we can have a look it's an
actual gameplay after that akula awesome
and this is just to remind people on
this game is I'm on iOS devices an
Android as well or will be right comes I
that's right okay great here we go
alright that wasn't very us I feel
teased I feel really tedious job but you
have been teased you well let's check
out the beer all next and then we can
watch it over and you can just tell me
explain what's going on what I'm really
interested in is how you actively
control an interracial you know with
your honor on a touch device you know
because I mean shooters don't generally
like shooters in general classic
shooters don't really transition that
well I don't think anyway yes a
touchscreen devices but cuz it's this
fixed position that's what really
interested to see that's right i mean it
you can see here right we've spent a lot
of time on the controls we iterated on
them a lot you can play the entire game
with one hand it's really one home that
it's very very accessible for you to get
into so we were using all the kind of
gestures and controls you would expect
from a touch device we pinch to zoom you
can zoom in and out like that it's a
simple tap to shoot and there's only two
buttons on the screen the reload on the
left and the whole breath on the right
down you're on your mark so here you've
got basically these are the marks guards
that are around the scene this guy's
about a light a cigarette he's probably
not going to get that far oh yeah so
you're holding breath while you're doing
that so it's all kind of slowed down so
basically what you're doing is you're
trying to pick these guys off without
raising the alert if you're too messy
about your approach oh you're too um
stealthy about it you could risk off you
see these some guys have become curious
now they're going to go an investigate
this is actually kind of cool this is
this is where we kind of encourage the
creativity so this guy got distracted
because he heard something another guy
looking down shoot the glass out kill
them both but as the kind of little
finisher there shoot the fan speed it up
dispose of both of the bodies at the
same time it's tons of stuff throughout
the level that's all like this I wish I
knew he was gonna get sucked into the
fan and which way you're going together
so here's another one as well you can
see you're actually zoomed in on the
power supply at the top there he kind of
gets distracted but then gets
electrocuted
time so there's accident kills there's
body disposals everything you would
expect from the hip man franchise is
here and it's it's really just about
that man's gonna swim that mouse goes
this guy's actually going for a swim
he's like a sign out there look at that
many use supersonic rounds supersonic
rounds allow you to hit your target
instantly so they get rid of the lead
time that you need to okay and we got a
whole bunch of power-ups in the game we
got a ton of different weapons all with
different personalities and their you
complete the contract by killing the
mark you bank your score and any of the
missions that you might have been doing
along the way there was one there for
three body disposals so it doesn't
matter that if you kill you mark before
you kill any of the guards like what
why'd you kill the mark before you
killed any of the other guards that's it
that's contract complete so what you
want to try and do is because it's a
high score game you want to try and kill
as many of the guys throughout the scene
as you possibly can in order to get the
high score and then the markets like the
last guy that you always take it you got
you know what that reminded me the
muslin it might remind a lot of people
watching off the most is if you've never
played hitman go I mean you might
remember they had mine sniper challenge
which was was a xbox live arcade or was
it just out it was xbox and pc I'm pc
right that's when you were shooting it
and the marks in a very similar way but
there's also pigeons as well the
equation that was really that was really
fun so at least very much like you can't
really brought that to say you know a
tablet devices which absolutely i mean
we really like what they done with with
cyber challenge what the guys are iowa
down there right quite a bunch of guys
and we thought that if we're going to go
if we're going to deliver an experience
for tablet it has to be done right so
there's no point taking something like a
fully fledged hitman game and try and
get all the controls on the screen or
even like a complex typing game you look
at some of the competitors on iOS
there's lots of dials and buttons and so
on right so essentially all we wanted to
do is is take what they've done in 29
for challenge and expand it out to a lot
of different types of contracts that
different types of gameplay and a lot of
replayability will provide one level
that you've seen there there's 150
different missions for that one level
and then even when you
finished all of those you still got all
out pushing the leaderboard earning more
cash upgrading your weapons getting more
boosters and things like that so how
many levels are there we've got new
contracts to start off with the one you
saw there was from Montenegro there's
another one in the pipe at the moment so
we launching worldwide with two
contracts and then what we want to do is
really wish work with the community well
we've hit my fans work with guys the the
you know fans of our game and we're
really gonna be listening to what people
like who want if they want us to do like
a reenactment of a classic hitman hit
will do that right we'll take you back
to New Orleans or to an opera house
we're perfectly happy to do that but if
we want something new we really want to
you know after this game has been in the
market for a while it's going to be
constantly evolving we're going to be
finessing things along the way so we
just want to make sure that we go where
the players want us to go okay so how
does them how does this fit in there
with baking a wider hitman lore cuz
they're you know how much being a game
around for a long time is a really hard
fight I mean so this do you like tap
into that story anyway I don't we
actually have kept it very very light
this is just just to show you this here
oh you've done in the Domino kill we've
set up the car alarm lured two guys
together and again you get a two-for-one
there which is always good for a laugh
but no in terms of narrative we've left
it kind of narrative light a little bit
and this could be one of the earliest
hits of him of forty seventh career it
could be one of the later ones it could
be the last one he ever does the guys
are I owe their very much more they got
more narrative horsepower than we have
we just delivered a great gameplay
experience so it's almost like once you
start playing the different types of
contracts it's almost like the greatest
it's cool well guys if you're watching a
home and you have any questions about
hitman sniper and the best thing to do
would be to tweet at me at cam fraz Rob
right now and I'll pier on my laptop
here and I can throw the question to
ollie so that's at cam fraz grub cmf raz
ro be there may well be a little lower
third appearing on screen any moment any
moment but Ollie yes what made you
decide to basically try to bring a man
to iOS like and to add joy to touch
devices like
well it's that decision with me mauling
on for hit for I guess you had hit my
goal before yeah I mean we we wanted to
see we think age of 47 is an awesome
character and that you know more people
need to we wanted to kind of diversify
the brand and just make everyone give
the opportunity to kind of get into his
shoes so for us the sniping experience
on a tablet device they seemed to kind
of match up really well with one another
and we really wanted to give agent 47
introduced him to more people Square
Enix Montreal was kind of set up in the
first place to do Triple A and we were
going to be doing the the follow-up to
absolution but at the same time we
realized that in order to diversify the
brand we can have a shorter development
time and delivered a lot of different
types of experiences to an entirely new
audience that may never have heard of
the hair man franchise or two of age of
47 so it seemed like a better track for
us to kind of diversify the brand so
here we're seeing some of their the kind
of various menus think so can you like
customize your weapons name yeah there's
tons of stuff you can do you see on the
left-hand side there or you could see on
the left-hand side all the different
types of scoring opportunities that you
have the higher your scores and the more
missions there we go the higher scores
and the more the more missions that you
complete you actually level up each one
of your weapons as you as you play with
them okay and as you level up the
weapons more they get more slots for
abilities they get new skills they'll
give you like little tweaks to your
score and then at the bottom there where
it's underneath where it says targets
eliminated you have the what we call I
roulette for every key target that you
take out throughout the level you get
rewarded apart for these blueprints that
you're actually can be waiting so you
actually assemble your weapons as you go
through the game now as I mentioned
before all the weapons have different
personalities they've all got different
low real low speeds different timings
they all feel a different kind of weight
they all got different personalities so
it's really up to you about how you want
to take take which weapon you want to
take with you and how you want to
customize it to for your your style of
play cool all right we gained some
questions flooding in a Twitter all
right later let's take some of these
cell where we go so George is asking
other different types of snipers are you
always the same sniper in it is
guns where you get your guns where you
hear the diverse I've got a whole bunch
of guns in there but you always play 47
okay cool Oh is interesting one any
chance you could put hitman sniper on
PlayStation Vita's coming from user
Keeneland at the moment we're targeting
iOS and Android but vita is something
that will definitely look into later on
down the line but you think you think
it's set up again that would go well to
anything like I piece anything where you
have more like more than just the touch
screens to save would you think we're
bringing it to PC as well I mean these
are all just conversations brother
deadlines are all conversations that
we're going to have further down the
line we'll see how this will get with a
see how successful the game is first and
then so fighting is it possible
basically on my the highly scientific
yeah Twitter comments I can see that
lost people are and quite keen to see
this and other things as well that's
cool I'm so you said you've got two
different scenarios two different maps
and in different types of missions
within those men yeah so what other
types of missions have we got so there
was a target there are there more other
more kind of complicated more nuanced
missions and yes the inside interesting
about Montenegro that you just saw but
both of our contracts are like they have
this same kind of spine so you start off
with the mark which is Marcus Krug in
Montenegro yeah as you play through the
game what happens is you actually unlock
new marks so the long you much you will
unlock new new characters to take down
there's a lot of civilians in the scene
to start off with and as the ICA start
getting in town I'm who's on the site
they actually start to say okay this
guy's a criminal that girl there is a
criminal she's also wanted and you
actually discovered that the this is
kind of like a Viper's nest of criminals
and Marcus cookies like the kingpin of
all of them so you get a lot of
variation every time you play through
where we shuffle whichever market is
that you need to take down to end your
contract but everyone else that you have
intel on before that actually remains
about a target and there's worth more
points to you so the whole level
involves as you carry on playing through
for the missions themselves you've got
some ones that start up very very simple
almost like tutorial izing the game and
because it's a leaderboard driven game
and we really want players to play with
one another we've got some real quite
tough challenges towards the end of
these missions well I can't wait to see
how that turns out when it comes
this fall is full right awesome if
you're a Brit like I autumn yes of
course mastic well he's been a pleasure
having you on their sofa sorry gonna
have to ask you to leave the comfy sofa
in just a minute that is incredibly nice
i'm gonna stay my orange chair